so we have the vector a being equal to 5
comma negative 6. so if we wanted to
visualize that we could start at the
tail of vector a
and we'd want to move 5 positive 5 in
the x direction so that would be 5 to
the right based on our conventions and
we'd want to move negative 6 in the y
directions and based on our conventions
that would be 6 down
6 down so this length would be
6. if this was a positive 6 we would
have moved 6 up over here
this length over here is five
and so
going five to the right and then six
down and then six down would take us
from the tail to the head
so now we are at the head or sometimes
well i'll just call it the head or i
guess you could say the tip or the arrow
side of the vector so let's
let's draw it just like that so that's a
reasonable representation for our vector
a
so let's see what else can we think
about how else can we think about this
vector
well what if we wanted to figure out its
magnitude well the magnitude of this
vector is just the length of this arrow
if we think of it visually and this is a
right triangle so this is really just we
need to figure out the length of the
hypotenuse of this right triangle we
know the lengths of the two shorter
sides so the magnitude of vector a
is just going to be equal to the square
root this is coming straight out of the
pythagorean theorem square root of 5
squared
5 squared plus 6 squared
plus 6 squared which is equal to the
square root of let's see 25 plus 36 is
61. so the length of this arrow right
over here square root of 61 which is a
little bit under 8 which actually just
makes visual sense
so that was interesting let's say we
want to do something else let's say we
wanted to figure out some unit vector
that goes in the same direction as a so
it's a unit vector so that means that
its length is 1 but it goes in the same
direction as a
well we've seen this before if we if we
call this unit vector u and i'll put the
little hat on top of it to show that
it's a unit vector
what we could do is we could take vector
a
we could take vector a and divide it by
essentially scale it down by the
magnitude by the magnitude
of vector a or another way of thinking
about it this would be equal to
so this part right over here
this would be we could rewrite this so
let me write it just so we don't get
confused or we could write it like this
we could say 1 over
the magnitude of vector a
times vector a
and so this makes it pretty clear we're
just scaling vector a so this part right
over here that's going to be equal to 1
over the square root of 61. we figured
out that this was already the square
root of 61. and we're going to multiply
it times vector a
which is
5 comma negative 6
comma
negative 6.
and so now we can scale it up or scale
it down in this case by just multiplying
the scalar times each of these
components so u
u is
equal to it's equal to
5 over the square root
of 61
comma all i'm doing is i'm scaling each
of the components in the x direction of
the y direction by 1 over square root of
comma
negative 6
over the square root of 61.
so that was interesting but now let's
ask ourselves another question what
would we have to multiply u by
to get to a what scalar could we
multiply it by to get a
well our answer is actually right over
here we see that the vector u is equal
to the vector a essentially divided by
the scalar so if you multiply both sides
times the scalar you get
the scale the magnitude of a which is
just a number it's just a length of this
side
times our unit vector times our unit
vector u
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to our original
vector
so if we wanted to write our original
vector kind of broken up this way we
could say that our original vector is
equal to its magnitude is equal to
square root of 61 square root of 61
times our unit vector
times our unit vector that makes sense
the length of this unit vector is one
square hund one square root of 61 of
this entire length right over here and
this of course is going to be the same
thing
as the square root of 61 squared is 61
times all of this business
so
copy
and paste times all that business and i
think it's it might jump out at you if
you multiply the scalar you're going to
multiply it times each of these
components you're going to be left with
5 comma negative 6. now the whole reason
why i did this is just to make a little
bit more comfortable with the different
ways of manipulating these notations
sometimes when you see this type of
thing with this you know these kind of
double lines on either side it looks
like something very fancy but it's
really just talking about the magnitude
of the vector the length of the vector
and so the whole point of this is just
to relate the vector itself to the
magnitude of the vector to a unit vector
going in the same direction